This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. What if you knew when you were going to die? How would it change the way you lived your life? I do feel like this is the year I need to be very careful. The way you relate to others, to your work. It's something that I just had held so close to my heart or to myself. And so I hesitated. I wondered if I should share it.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。如果你知道自己什么时候会死，会怎样？这会如何改变你的生活方式？我确实觉得今年我需要非常小心。你与他人、与工作的相处方式。这是我一直深藏在心底或留给自己的东西。所以我犹豫了。我不知道是否应该分享它。
Would you feel unshackled from community norms, cut off other cars in traffic and show up drunk to work? Would you take that trip you've always wanted and try to squeeze every last pleasure from life? Or would you try to do all the good that was possible in the moments you had left? You know if I don't make it through this year there's some things I want to get finished up. This week on Hidden Brain a premonition that haunted one man for decades and what the knowledge of death can tell us about a
你会感到摆脱了社会规范的束缚，在交通中强行超车，醉醺醺地去上班吗？你会去那趟你一直想去的旅行，试图从生活中榨取最后一点快乐吗？还是你会试图在剩下的时间里尽可能多地做善事？你知道，如果我今年没能挺过去，有些事情我想完成。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，一个困扰了一个男人几十年的预感，以及对死亡的认知能告诉我们关于……
life well lived. One night when Paul Burnham was 15 years old. He had a dream. In the dream I was traveling kind of on a flat area or in a deep canyon and I was in the very bottom of it. And on either side of me were, there's these enormous cliffs and the walls were just a thousand feet, just these huge, you know, these enormous walls. I felt like someone was with me there, maybe behind me. And as we traveled along, we came to a bend in that canyon.
……美好生活的一些启示。保罗·伯纳姆15岁那晚，他做了一个梦。在梦里，我正走在一片平坦的区域或一个深峡谷里，我处于最底部。我的两侧是巨大的悬崖，墙壁有上千英尺高，就是那些巨大的、你知道的，那些巨大的墙壁。我觉得有人和我在一起，可能在我身后。当我们沿着峡谷走时，我们来到了一个弯道。
And as we saw that bend, there was a big, large cut in the cliffs or in the canyon walls. Even in the dream, Paul remembers it was dramatic. The tall cliffs of the canyon suddenly fell away. And I looked and saw this big cut coming down through the cliffs, kind of a ramp coming down through the cliffs, kind of a ramp coming down through the cliffs. As we saw that, I turned around, and I looked at the person that was with me, and he leaned back, and I woke up.
当我们看到那个弯道时，悬崖或峡谷壁上有一个巨大的缺口。即使在梦中，保罗也记得那非常引人注目。峡谷高耸的悬崖突然消失了。我抬头看，看到这个巨大的缺口穿过悬崖，就像一条斜坡穿过悬崖，就像一条斜坡穿过悬崖。当我们看到那个时，我转过身，看着和我在一起的那个人，他向后靠去，然后我就醒了。
When Paul woke up, it was a hot summer night. So he got up and opened the window to let in the breeze and went back to bed. When I went back to sleep I had a second dream. In the second dream Paul was playing a game called a paper fortune teller. Sometimes it's called a kuri catcher. A piece of paper is folded up into squares and you're presented with several choices with a unique color or number. Once you choose an option, a flap is opened to reveal your fortune.
保罗醒来时，那是一个炎热的夏夜。于是他起床打开窗户让微风吹进来，又回去睡觉了。当我再次入睡时，我做了第二个梦。在第二个梦里，保罗正在玩一个叫“纸算命”的游戏。有时它被称为“东南西北”。一张纸被折叠成正方形，你会被提供几个带有独特颜色或数字的选择。一旦你选择了一个选项，就会打开一个翻盖来揭示你的命运。
I opened it up and I looked at everything inside and on the inside were just a series of numbers. And I thought, okay, this is a game that a person plays, and the answer is how long you're going to live, how many years you're going to live. The game presented Paul with eight choices. He picked one. It opened up to the number 54. He made a second choice. Again, 54. The third, the fourth, the fifth, 54. 54. 54. And what I found is no matter what I chose, no matter how I started, no matter how I changed my
我打开它，看着里面的所有东西，里面只是一连串的数字。我想，好吧，这是一个人们玩的游戏，答案是你将活多久，你将活多少年。这个游戏给了保罗八个选择。他选了一个。它打开显示数字54。他做了第二个选择。又是54。第三个、第四个、第五个，都是54。54。54。我发现无论我选择什么，无论我怎么开始，无论我怎么改变我的……
choices or changed how I started the game, I always landed on the same number and that was 54. And in my dream I felt like this is telling me that I'm going to live until I'm 54 years old. When Paul woke up, he thought the two dreams were strange. But with dreams, the strange is normal, so he put them out of his mind. Two years later, he went off to college at Brigham Young University in Utah. One summer, between semesters, he took a job as a wilderness ranger in Southeast Alaska. And the person I was working with, his name is James, we would spend ten days at a time out in the wilderness.
……选择或改变我开始游戏的方式，我总是落在同一个数字上，那就是54。在梦里，我觉得这在告诉我，我将活到54岁。保罗醒来时，觉得这两个梦很奇怪。但对于梦来说，奇怪是正常的，所以他没放在心上。两年后，他去犹他州的杨百翰大学上大学。一个暑假，在学期之间，他在阿拉斯加东南部找了一份荒野护林员的工作。和我一起工作的那个人，他叫詹姆斯，我们每次要在荒野中待十天。
The landscape was vast and wild, endless forests of pine trees, crystal clear waters, dramatic rugged cliffs. Everything that we saw wildlife, people, old mining camps, anything that we found, we were to document that. And so we worked both on land, just crossing open ground. And then we also worked on the coast, and we had a boat. And one day we went up one of the, what they call an arm or a fjord. And the weather was pretty calm.
那里的风景广阔而狂野，无尽的松树林，清澈见底的水域，引人注目的崎岖悬崖。我们看到的任何东西，野生动物、人、旧矿营地，我们发现的任何东西，都要记录下来。所以我们在陆地上工作，穿过开阔地。我们也沿海岸工作，我们有一条船。有一天，我们沿着他们所说的“臂”或峡湾向上走。天气相当平静。
The sea was pretty flat. And both sides of this arm were bounded or bordered by just sheer cliffs coming right down to the water. And as we were traveling up, we were talking about going all the way to the end of this arm, where we would see a glacier. But we also wondered if there would be a place to get out, would there be a place to pull the boat out, to stop, to get out, to hike around. And as we were going up this arm,
海面相当平坦。这条“臂”的两侧被直插水中的陡峭悬崖所包围或限制。当我们向上行驶时，我们谈论着一直走到这条“臂”的尽头，在那里我们会看到冰川。但我们也想知道是否有地方可以上岸，是否有地方可以把船停下来，下船，四处徒步。当我们沿着这条“臂”向上走时，
there was a bend ahead of us. And I started to have that feeling of deja vu a little bit. I started to feel like I recognized this place, like I had been there, though I had never actually been to this place. And so I told James, I said, James, cut the engine. And I wanted to just kind of reflect and think about this because the feeling that I was having was fairly strong, that I had seen this place before before but I didn't know when or where
前方有一个弯道。我开始有一种似曾相识的感觉。我开始觉得我认得这个地方，好像我来过这里，尽管我从未真正来过这个地方。所以我告诉詹姆斯，我说，詹姆斯，关掉引擎。我想反思一下，思考一下，因为我当时的感觉相当强烈，我以前见过这个地方，但我不知道是什么时候或在哪里。
and he cut the engine and we just stopped and we were floating and I started to remember that dream that I had had. The first dream he'd had that night when he was 15. I started to recognize the elements of that dream and the cliffs coming down to the bottom of this canyon. When I remembered in the dream, I went around a corner and there was a big break in the cliffs, a big opening. And so I turned around, I said to James, we're going to go around this corner We're going to go around this corner and there'll be a break in these cliffs. And he kind of looked at me funny. That's all I said to him is that here's what we're going to see. I think I described it a little bit that it would be a break, it would come right down to the water. We would be able to get right up to it.
他关掉了引擎，我们只是停在那里漂浮着，我开始想起我做的那个梦。他15岁那晚做的第一个梦。我开始认出那个梦的元素，悬崖一直延伸到峡谷底部。当我在梦中回忆时，我绕过一个拐角，悬崖上有一个巨大的缺口，一个巨大的开口。所以我转过身，对詹姆斯说，我们要绕过这个拐角，我们要绕过这个拐角，这些悬崖上会有一个缺口。他有点奇怪地看着我。我只对他说了这些，这就是我们将要看到的东西。我想我稍微描述了一下，它会是一个缺口，它会一直延伸到水边。我们将能够直接到达那里。
And so we started the engine again and we motor it along for a few minutes and we came around that bend in the long arm and there was a break in the cliffs. And I remember in the dream the person I was with leaned back and when we were in the boat James leaned back and he kind of looked up at the top of the cliffs and looked up at the the sky and he just laughed and laughed and I started laughing because it was so funny that that I had described exactly what we were seeing I I I described it fairly well. He asked me how I knew it and I just told him,
于是我们再次启动引擎，我们又行驶了几分钟，绕过了长臂的那个弯道，悬崖上果然有一个缺口。我记得在梦里，和我在一起的那个人向后靠去，当我们在船上时，詹姆斯向后靠去，他抬头看着悬崖顶部，看着天空，他只是大笑不止，我也开始笑，因为这太有趣了，我竟然准确地描述了我们正在看到的东西，我描述得相当好。他问我是怎么知道的，我只是告诉他，
I've had a dream of this place. I've seen this place before. They pulled the boat out onto a rocky beach where the cliffs came down. They went for a hike. They had lunch. At first, Paul thought it was cool that he'd had a dream that foretold what the two friends had just seen. But then he started to worry. He remembered he'd had two dreams that night. This is telling me that I'm going to live in telling 54 years old. I mean that I'm going to live until I'm 54 years old. For the rest of that afternoon and that evening,
我梦见过这个地方。我以前见过这个地方。他们把船拉到悬崖延伸下来的岩石海滩上。他们去徒步旅行。他们吃了午饭。起初，保罗觉得他做了一个预言了两个朋友刚刚看到的梦，这很酷。但随后他开始担心。他记得那天晚上他做了两个梦。这在告诉我，我将活到54岁。我是说我将活到54岁。那天下午和晚上的剩余时间里，
I just thought about those two dreams and wondered what it meant. One dream had come true, and with the other dream come true. Now, I should stop here and tell you something about Paul. Like me, he prizes rationality. Dreams we rationalist know are not premonitions. They're just, well, dreams. But Paul asked himself what the odds were that a dream would so perfectly describe the cliffs he and James had just seen.
我一直在想那两个梦，想知道这意味着什么。一个梦成真了，另一个梦会成真吗？现在，我应该在这里停下来告诉你关于保罗的一些事情。像我一样，他推崇理性。我们理性主义者知道梦不是预感。它们只是，嗯，梦。但保罗问自己，一个梦如此完美地描述了他和詹姆斯刚刚看到的悬崖，这种几率是多少。
Paul felt like he had been told something, shown something. I think I just started to feel maybe the gravity or the... that maybe there's more meaning to this, that it's not just a coincidence. not just a coincidence. If the first dream was a premonition, could the second be a premonition too? Was it possible that he really had received a vision about when he was going to die? There was one silver lining. Paul was only 22. 54, that was an eternity away. Where we come back, eternity flies by.
保罗觉得他被告知了什么，被展示了什么。我想我只是开始感觉到也许这种重要性，或者……也许这不仅仅是巧合，这不仅仅是巧合。如果第一个梦是预感，第二个梦会不会也是预感？他真的收到了关于他何时会死的启示，这可能吗？有一个一线希望。保罗才22岁。54岁，那是一个永恒的距离。当我们回来时，永恒飞逝。
How old are you Napa? I am 52, I'll be 53 next week. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. More than 400 years ago, William Shakespeare wrote a tragic play about one man's meteoric rise and epic fall. He called it Macbeth. The tale that Shakespeare tells in Macbeth begins with a series of prophecies, three which is share of vision with Macbeth. He is going to be promoted to a new title in the Scottish aristocracy. Macbeth held to the Santa Codary. When that prophecy comes true, Megbeth starts to believe a second prediction made by the witches. Therefore, see that he will become king. Soon, Megbeth starts to take steps to make the prophecy come true. He kills the king and usurps the throne.
你多大了，纳帕？我52岁，下周就53岁了。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。400多年前，威廉·莎士比亚写了一部关于一个人迅速崛起又史诗般陨落的悲剧。他称之为《麦克白》。莎士比亚在《麦克白》中讲述的故事始于一系列预言，三个女巫与麦克白分享了一个愿景。他将被提升为苏格兰贵族中的一个新头衔。当那个预言成真时，麦克白开始相信女巫做出的第二个预测。因此，他将成为国王。很快，麦克白开始采取行动使预言成真。他杀死了国王并篡夺了王位。
But in the end, Macbeth is killed. The Omen ends in tragedy. Paul Burnham had two strange dreams when he was 15. When one came true, he started to ask if the second dream might also come true. Would he really die at 54? For a long time, the question felt abstract. He told himself that 54 was a long ways away. Then Paul found himself turning 53. That's when I first spoke with him. That's when I first spoke with him. So I am Paul Burnham. I listened to Hidden Brain quite often and I was listening to the podcast and I was driving on the freeway and I heard the invitation to send in secrets or things that we felt
但最终，麦克白被杀。预兆以悲剧告终。保罗·伯纳姆15岁时做了两个奇怪的梦。当一个成真时，他开始问第二个梦是否也可能成真。他真的会死在54岁吗？很长一段时间里，这个问题感觉很抽象。他告诉自己54岁还很遥远。然后保罗发现自己快53岁了。那时我第一次和他交谈。那时我第一次和他交谈。所以我就是保罗·伯纳姆。我经常听《隐藏的大脑》，我正在听播客，当时我正在高速公路上开车，我听到了发送秘密或我们觉得……
were secrets and you know what we had gained, what we had lost by keeping that secret. And then when I got home later in the day, I nearly didn't do it. I thought about maybe just not worrying about it, but I kept thinking about it and decided to record that and send that in. And when you had some hesitation about it, Paul, what was that hesitation about? The hesitation mostly was that I had never shared this story with anyone, and it's something that I just had held so close to my heart or to myself, and so I hesitated. I wondered if I should share it.
……是秘密的事情的邀请，你知道我们得到了什么，因为保守那个秘密我们失去了什么。然后当我那天晚些时候回家时，我差点没做。我想也许不用担心它，但我一直在想它，并决定记录下来并发送出去。当你对此有一些犹豫时，保罗，那犹豫是关于什么的？犹豫主要是因为我从未与任何人分享过这个故事，这是我一直深藏在心底或留给自己的东西，所以我犹豫了。我不知道是否应该分享它。
As Paul approached 54, the unformed anxiety in his heart that began at age 22 started to take concrete shape. The more he thought about the second dream, the more he realized it was ambiguous. I am 52, I'll be 53 next week. And when you're 53, you're in your 54th year. So I'm not sure if I have a year or if I have not a year. I don't know. When Paul is nervous, he laughs. It's a tick I noticed as I got to know him.
随着保罗接近54岁，他22岁时心中开始形成的未成形的焦虑开始变得具体。他越想第二个梦，就越意识到它是模棱两可的。我52岁，下周就53岁了。当你53岁时，你处于你的第54个年头。所以我不知道我还有一年，还是没有一年。我不知道。当保罗紧张时，他会笑。这是我了解他时注意到的一个习惯。
As we talked, he corrected his comment that he'd never share the story of the two dreams with anyone. He told me he had told two people about the second dream. One time, some years ago, he got in a conversation with a couple of colleagues. The young man that I was talking to, he said something like, well, we just never know when our time will come. And I said, well, I think I do. I think I do when no one in my time will come. And I said, well, I think I do. I think I do when no one my time will come. And he kind of looked at me, finding out.
当我们交谈时，他纠正了他从未与任何人分享过这两个梦的故事的评论。他告诉我他曾告诉过两个人关于第二个梦的事。有一次，几年前，他与几位同事交谈。我正在交谈的那个年轻人，他说了一些类似的话，嗯，我们永远不知道我们的时间什么时候会到。我说，嗯，我想我知道。我想我知道我的时间什么时候会到。我说，嗯，我想我知道。我想我知道我的时间什么时候会到。他有点奇怪地看着我。
And he said, what do you mean? No one can know that. And I said, oh, you know, one time I had a dream. And I shared the dream with him. And afterwards, I regretted that a little bit because I felt like maybe I had shared some burden with them, that what I was carrying, I needed to carry. That burden was heavy, and he didn't want anyone else to be weighed down by it.
他说，你是什么意思？没有人能知道那个。我说，哦，你知道，有一次我做了一个梦。我与他分享了那个梦。事后，我有点后悔，因为我觉得也许我与他们分享了一些负担，我所承受的，我需要自己承受。那个负担很重，他不想让其他人被它压垮。
After he'd seen the first dream come true in Alaska, Paul had graduated college. He'd gotten married. He had two kids. But he never breathed a word about the two dreams to his family. Prophecy or not, he felt this was his cross to carry. After that first interview, Paul checked in with me every few months. He would also occasionally send me voice recordings of his thoughts.
在阿拉斯加看到第一个梦成真后，保罗大学毕业了。他结婚了。他有两个孩子。但他从未向家人透露过这两个梦的只言片语。无论是不是预言，他觉得这是他必须背负的十字架。那次采访后，保罗每隔几个月就会和我联系。他偶尔也会给我发送他想法的语音记录。
Hi, Shankar. It's Saturday, a couple days ahead of my birthday, and I've been fishing with my son in a kind of a remote corner of Yellowstone National Park we hiked in this morning and we've just been fishing all day. It's sunny and cool and we put up our hammocks and had lunch and took a two hour nap and we're going to start fishing again. How do I feel today? Well, I feel indestructible or invincible. We'll see how I feel on Monday, on my birthday.
嗨，尚卡尔。今天是星期六，离我生日还有几天，我和我儿子在黄石国家公园的一个偏远角落钓鱼，我们今天早上徒步进来的，我们整天都在钓鱼。天气晴朗凉爽，我们挂上吊床吃了午饭，睡了两个小时，我们打算再开始钓鱼。我今天感觉如何？嗯，我觉得坚不可摧或不可战胜。我们看看周一，也就是我生日那天，我感觉如何。
Happy birthday to you. Happy birthday to you. Happy Birthday dear mom. Happy Birthday to you. Here's how you put candles out, blow candles out during COVID. You switch your hand at it. I thought you were going to say it. You're helping. Hi, Shankar. It's September 9.
祝你生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。祝亲爱的妈妈生日快乐。祝你生日快乐。这就是你在新冠期间吹灭蜡烛的方法。你用手挥动它。我以为你会说出来。你在帮忙。嗨，尚卡尔。今天是9月9日。
I'm two days into my 54th year. I thought about being 53 and being in my 54th year. I don't think my 15-year-old intellect understood that turning 53 is the same as being in my 54th year. I think my dream was clearly about being 54, turning 54. So, I'm going to relax this year. I've got a year to go. After I received that recording, I assumed that Paul had put his worries to rest for at least the next year.
我进入54岁已经两天了。我考虑过53岁并处于54岁这一年。我想我15岁时的智力并不理解53岁与处于54岁这一年是一样的。我想我的梦显然是关于54岁，进入54岁。所以，我今年要放松一下。我还有一年时间。收到那段录音后，我以为保罗至少在接下来的一年里已经把他的担忧抛在脑后了。
But then a couple of months later, he sent me another voice memo that suggested his fears was still with him. I had a close call the other evening while on a walk and crossing the street at a not well lit intersection. Many van made a sudden left turn right where I was crossing. And I went into what I'd call a dream state, that place where our brains processed minutes, or hours of thoughts and memories in only a moment. As the Minivan was corining toward me,
但几个月后，他给我发了另一条语音备忘录，暗示他的恐惧仍然伴随着他。前几天晚上散步时，我在一个光线不足的十字路口过马路，差点出事。一辆面包车在我过马路的地方突然左转。我进入了我所说的梦境状态，那是我们的大脑在瞬间处理几分钟或几小时的思想和记忆的地方。当面包车向我冲来时，
I saw the driver's face illuminated by her cell phone. She hadn't seen me, and she wasn't planning on stopping. In that moment, my thoughts turned to the two dreams and I replayed them both in my head as though I were checking to see if a car accident was in one of them. If I had seen what was about to happen, fortunately at the last second the driver looked up and slammed.
我看到司机的脸被她的手机照亮了。她没看见我，她也没打算停下来。那一刻，我的思绪转向了那两个梦，我在脑海中重演了它们，就像我在检查车祸是否在其中一个梦里一样。如果我看到了即将发生的事情，幸运的是在最后一秒，司机抬头猛踩……
On her brakes and I walked on and she drove away. That was the end of it. But as I walked home, I wasn't really rattled or phased by the near accident itself. But what occupied my thoughts was how much I was able to remember and recall and process in that brief moment before the driver stopped. Ideas that I had reflected on for years, that I had written down on scraps of paper and reread and pondered all these hours of thought. All of this was compressed into one moment.
……刹车，我继续走，她开车离开了。事情就这样结束了。但当我走回家时，我并没有因为这次险些发生的事故本身而感到惊慌或不安。但占据我思绪的是，在司机停车前的短暂瞬间，我能够记住、回忆和处理多少东西。我思考了多年的想法，我写在纸片上并反复阅读和思考的所有这些小时的思想。所有这些都被压缩成了一个瞬间。
And I realized that every time for the last 30 years, whenever I remembered these two dreams, I realized I was spending a lot of time rehashing and re-analysing and resorting the events and worrying and wondering if the second dream would come true. As Paul walked home, he couldn't stop thinking about his near brush with death. He couldn't elude the feeling that he had been shown something, that a clock was sticking down the hours. The minivan seemed like more than just a harbinger of death. It seemed like a symbol for the burden he had carried for more than 30 years. So before I got home, I decided to take all of these thoughts and the motion and energy that accompanied the memory of these two
我意识到，过去30年里，每当我记起这两个梦时，我意识到我花了很多时间重温、重新分析和重新整理这些事件，担心并想知道第二个梦是否会成真。当保罗走回家时，他无法停止思考他与死亡的擦肩而过。他无法摆脱那种他被展示了什么的、时钟正在滴答作响的感觉。面包车看起来不仅仅是死亡的预兆。它似乎是他背负了30多年的负担的象征。所以在回家之前，我决定把所有这些想法以及伴随着这两个梦的记忆的动作和能量……
dreams and to name them. So I called it the minivan. And what I was doing was putting all of this in a box. I was putting a complex and sometimes confusing problem in a single place where I could contain and manage it. Now when something reminds me of the dreams and all of the thoughts and emotions start coming to the surface, instead of trying to sort everything out again, I just remember that I've sorted this out before. I've organized it already. I don't have to do it again.
……命名。所以我叫它“面包车”。我所做的是把所有这些都放进一个盒子里。我把一个复杂且有时令人困惑的问题放在一个我可以控制和管理的地方。现在，当有什么东西提醒我这些梦，所有的想法和情绪开始浮出水面时，我不再试图再次整理一切，我只是记得我已经整理过这些了。我已经组织好它了。我不必再做一次了。
I just think, oh, here comes the minivan. Except, it wasn't so easy for Paul to keep the minivan under control. The more we talked, the more it became clear that the two dreams were continuing to bother him. I think about it just about every day. I think it's mostly random. There are moments when it does pop up, usually when I'm crossing the street or in heavy traffic or something like that. I don't dwell on it or think about it for a long time. But it does pop into my mind probably every day for a minute or two.
我只是想，哦，面包车来了。只是，保罗要控制住这辆“面包车”并不容易。我们谈得越多，就越清楚这两个梦一直在困扰他。我几乎每天都在想它。我认为这大多是随机的。有些时刻它确实会冒出来，通常是在我过马路或交通拥堵或类似的时候。我不会纠结于它或长时间思考它。但它确实每天都会在我脑海中闪现一两分钟。
But it does pop into my mind probably every day for a minute or two. Paul had still not shared his concerns with his wife Kim. He kept debating whether he should. The rationalist in him kept arguing the case that dreams were just dreams. I've often thought, you know, it's just a dream. I've had thousands of dreams. None of them have come true, except the one, and the coincides with this other one. At times, when he'd make the case to me
但它确实每天都会在我脑海中闪现一两分钟。保罗仍然没有与他的妻子金分享他的担忧。他一直在争论他是否应该这样做。他内心中的理性主义者一直在争论梦只是梦。我经常想，你知道，这只是一个梦。我做过成千上万个梦。没有一个成真，除了那一个，而且它与另一个巧合。有时，当他向我陈述……
that he was putting the fear out of his head, I wondered how much he was talking to me, and how much he was talking to himself. I think I'm very hopeful that it's just a dream. I've become really hopeful that the dream has simply caused me to maybe become more focused or become more aware, but that it's not something that's going to actually happen. But then he'd think, okay, but what if? What if this wasn't just a dream?
……他正在把恐惧从脑海中赶走时，我怀疑他是在对我说话，还是在对自己说话。我想我非常希望这只是一个梦。我变得非常希望这个梦只是让我变得更加专注或更加清醒，但它不是一件真正会发生的事情。但随后他会想，好吧，但是如果呢？如果这不仅仅是一个梦呢？
As I talked with Paul, I felt myself wavering about the meaning of the dream. Of course it was just a dream I'd tell myself. And then a voice inside me would ask, but what if it was more than that? If Paul did die in his 54th year, would I have to have a conversation with his wife and kids? Would I have to explain to them that Paul had told me his fears, recorded his fears? And I had just sat on the information and scoffed that it was just a dream? I think it's something that still is challenging for me to understand and to see that maybe there is a limit to you know rationality and I've pushed beyond that and and seen something that I
当我和保罗交谈时，我感到自己对梦的含义动摇了。当然，我告诉自己这只是一个梦。然后我内心的声音会问，但如果它不仅仅是那样呢？如果保罗真的死在他54岁那年，我是否必须与他的妻子和孩子进行谈话？我是否必须向他们解释保罗曾告诉我他的恐惧，记录了他的恐惧？而我只是坐在信息上，嘲笑它只是一个梦？我想这仍然是我难以理解和看到的事情，也许理性是有极限的，你知道，我超越了那个极限，看到了我……
Can't describe I can't I can't explain Yeah, I mean the striking thing again I think a lot of people have dreams and premonitions But I think that the striking thing in your in your case and your story is that you had these two dreams in the same night And then one of them came true in such a dramatic and vivid manner. I think that's what if I had had the same experience, I think my own confidence in my rationality would also have been shaken. Yeah. Because it really feels like you've been shown that one of the dreams can come true. Yeah, shaken. That's probably a good way to describe how I felt then and sometimes how
……无法描述、无法解释的东西。是的，我的意思是，再次令人震惊的事情是，我认为很多人都有梦和预感。但我认为在你的案例和你的故事中，令人震惊的是你在同一个晚上做了这两个梦。然后其中一个以如此戏剧性和生动的方式成真了。我想如果我有同样的经历，我想我自己对理性的信心也会动摇。是的。因为这真的感觉就像你被展示了其中一个梦是可以成真的。是的，动摇。这可能是一个描述我当时感觉的好方法，有时当我打开“面包车”并把所有东西拿出来再次查看时……
I feel when I open up the minivan and pull everything out and look at it again. Yeah. As we talked every few months, his 54th birthday approached. Paul asked himself at one point whether the dream might be telling him something rather than showing him something. Was it less a prophecy and more a warning? So I've put a countdown timer on my phone. Have you really? I have. It's just an app. You've probably seen it.
……我也会有这种感觉。是的。当我们每隔几个月交谈时，他的54岁生日临近了。保罗在某个时刻问自己，这个梦可能是在告诉他什么，而不是在展示他什么。它是一个预言还是一个警告？所以我给我的手机设置了一个倒计时器。你真的设置了吗？我设置了。这只是一个应用程序。你可能见过它。
You can just put in there a specific date and it counts down to it. And so I've put a countdown timer in and and the name of the timer is, be careful now. Right now I'm fine, I'm indestructible, I'm invincible. But when I do look at it, I think, okay, I'll need to be careful that maybe there are things I wouldn't do, maybe I wouldn't go mountain climbing or something like that, I'll just be more careful this year. I see. And have you actually taken any steps, concrete steps to basically plan ahead for if your
你可以在里面输入一个特定的日期，它会倒计时到那个日期。所以我设置了一个倒计时器，计时器的名字是，“现在要小心”。现在我很好，我是坚不可摧的，我是不可战胜的。但当我看着它时，我想，好吧，我需要小心，也许有些事情我不该做，也许我不该去爬山或类似的事情，我今年会更小心。我明白了。你是否真的采取了任何步骤，具体的步骤来为如果你的……
life were to end after you turn 54 or when you turn 54? You know, probably the most concrete step I took is I just renewed a life insurance policy. And I have to laugh. I have to laugh about that because I am very rational in my thought and my approach to things so much so that, you know, when this first dream came true, it gave me pause. It really caused me to stand back and say, wow, this has really happened. This is very clearly something that I've seen before. Can this other thing happen as well? So, yeah, taking out a life insurance policy, I don't know that it becomes more concrete than that.
……生命在你54岁之后或当你54岁时结束做准备？你知道，我采取的最具体的步骤可能就是我刚刚续签了一份人寿保险单。我不得不笑。我不得不对此发笑，因为我在思考和处理事情的方法上非常理性，以至于，你知道，当第一个梦成真时，它让我停顿了一下。它真的让我退后一步说，哇，这真的发生了。这非常清楚地是我以前见过的事情。这另一件事也会发生吗？所以，是的，购买人寿保险单，我不知道还有什么比这更具体的了。
policy. I don't know that it becomes more concrete than that. It's interesting when you fill out a life insurance policy, I'm assuming there's no clause there which says, have you had premonitions? As I renewed this one, I looked for it and there's nothing in there like that. So you have a clean conscience as you've applied for the policy. Yeah, there's no fraud. There's no fraud involved. As I listen back to that exchange some weeks later, I found myself asking, was my laughter nervous laughter too? When we come back, Paul turns 54. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
……单。我不知道还有什么比这更具体的了。有趣的是，当你填写人寿保险单时，我假设里面没有条款说，你有过预感吗？当我续签这一份时，我找了找，里面没有那样的东西。所以你在申请保单时问心无愧。是的，没有欺诈。没有涉及欺诈。几周后当我回听那次交流时，我发现自己在问，我的笑声也是紧张的笑声吗？当我们回来时，保罗54岁了。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。
For decades, Paul Burnham lived with the weight of two dreams he'd had when he was 15. Dreams that suggested he might die at the age of 54. The first dream came true. So Paul thought the second the dream that predicted he would die might also come to pass. As Paul was in his 54th year, he wondered if he should tell his family about the two dreams. I've gone back and forth. Do I share this? Do I not share this?
几十年来，保罗·伯纳姆一直带着他15岁时做的两个梦的重担生活。这些梦暗示他可能会在54岁时死去。第一个梦成真了。所以保罗认为第二个预测他会死的梦也可能成真。当保罗处于54岁这一年时，他想知道是否应该告诉家人这两个梦。我一直在反复思考。我分享这个吗？我不分享这个吗？
And more and more, I'm coming to a place where maybe I need to, because as much as I think that it would place a heavy burden on those closest to me, maybe it would also be an opportunity to just have a gigantic belly laugh and we all laugh it off and it's a crazy dream and we go on or it becomes a concern and you know my wife worries and is concerned and it affects her. That's what I keep going back and forth on. It was a dilemma. He wasn't sure of his wife would want to know, but the only way to find out if she wanted to know was to ask her. Of course, that would take away her choice in
而且越来越多地，我来到一个地方，也许我需要分享，因为尽管我认为这会给最亲近的人带来沉重的负担，但也许这也是一个机会，可以进行一次巨大的开怀大笑，我们都一笑置之，这是一个疯狂的梦，我们继续生活，或者它成为一个担忧，你知道我妻子担心并关心，这影响了她。这就是我一直在反复思考的问题。这是一个两难境地。他不确定他的妻子是否想知道，但找出她是否想知道的唯一方法就是问她。当然，那会剥夺她在这件事上的选择权。在我看来，保罗在等待一个信号，然后他收到了一个。
the matter. It seemed to me that Paul was waiting for a sign, and then he received one. Hi, Shankar. It's Paul, and I'm halfway down Dang Canyon. As in dang, this is a hard canyon. There's a lot of rock fall and pools of water to get through. through a couple of holes. They have ice in them. See if the rock will break through. Nope. Anyway, I've just stopped for lunch and I'm going to eat and rest here for a little while. A few months ago when you and I spoke on the phone, part of our conversation was, should I let my family know that I've had these two dreams and share my concern with them. And I've wondered about that often on since then, and how would I ever know, until a week or two ago. And we were watching an episode of Lost.
嗨，尚卡尔。我是保罗，我正在“危险峡谷”的半路上。就像“危险”一样，这是一个艰难的峡谷。有很多落石和水池要穿过。穿过几个洞。里面有冰。看看石头会不会穿过去。没有。总之，我刚停下来吃午饭，我打算在这里吃点东西休息一会儿。几个月前当你和我在电话里交谈时，我们谈话的一部分是，我是否应该让我的家人知道我做了这两个梦并与他们分享我的担忧。从那以后我经常想这个问题，我怎么会知道呢，直到一两周前。我们正在看一集《迷失》。
I think it was in season five. The TV show Lost features a group of plain crash survivors on a remote island. One of them, Charlie, receives a prophecy. He is going to die. Later, he goes on a dangerous mission, knowing there's a good chance he will drown. Before he leaves, he says goodbye to his girlfriend Claire. He doesn't mention his potential death. I'm gone.
我想是在第五季。电视剧《迷失》讲述了一群空难幸存者在一个偏远岛屿上的故事。其中一个人，查理，收到了一个预言。他会死。后来，他去执行一项危险的任务，知道他很有可能会淹死。在他离开之前，他向他的女朋友克莱尔告别。他没有提到他潜在的死亡。我走了。
Don't worry about me. Paul was watching the show with his wife Kim and his daughter Mary. I paused the show and I said, what do you think? Do you think Charlie should tell her? Because obviously he's not going to, but do you think he should? And Kim and Mary both responded with a resounding no way. And I said, why not? And they both agreed that it would be really hard for her. It would cause her a lot of pain knowing that he knew that he was going to die. So I got my answer, I think, of
别担心我。保罗正和他的妻子金以及女儿玛丽一起看这部剧。我暂停了节目，我说，你们怎么看？你们认为查理应该告诉她吗？因为显然他不会，但你们认为他应该吗？金和玛丽都以响亮的“绝不”回应。我说，为什么不呢？她们俩都同意这对她来说会非常困难。知道他知道自己要死，会给她带来很多痛苦。所以我得到了我的答案，我想，响亮的“绝不”，她们不想知道。好吧，我要继续徒步走下这个峡谷，稍后再联系你。
resounding no way they would not want to know. All right, I am going to keep hiking down this canyon and I'll catch up to you later. later. Sometime after, I got Paul on the line. It was his birthday. He was now 54. Hey, Paul. Hi, Shankar. Hey, happy birthday.
此后不久，我联系上了保罗。那是他的生日。他现在54岁了。嘿，保罗。嗨，尚卡尔。嘿，生日快乐。
Thanks so much. How do you feel today? Really good. Really alive. Yeah. Feel great. A lot of thoughts and a lot of emotion this morning. I've made it. I've made it this far. I'm wondering if you can tell me what your first thought was
非常感谢。你今天感觉如何？非常好。真的很有活力。是的。感觉很棒。今天早上有很多想法和很多情绪。我做到了。我走到这一步了。我想知道你能告诉我你早上醒来时的第一个想法是什么吗？
when you woke up in the morning. Well, I just, I thought about how many years it's been since I had this dream of turning 54 or not making it past 54. I guess you could say I opened the minivan. I brought out all these thoughts and emotions and I do feel like this is the year I need to be very careful, not overly cautious, not I don't want to do things that would create a problem, but rather just take a little more care in what I do. And thinking that, well, if this does happen, if I don't make it through this year, there's some things I want to get finished up and resolved, and not leaving loose ends, as it were.
嗯，我只是，我想到了我做那个关于54岁或没能活过54岁的梦已经过去多少年了。我想你可以说我打开了“面包车”。我拿出了所有这些想法和情绪，我确实觉得今年我需要非常小心，不是过度谨慎，不是我不想做那些会制造问题的事情，而是要在我的行为中多加小心。并认为，好吧，如果这真的发生了，如果我今年没能挺过去，有些事情我想完成并解决，不留下任何悬念，正如他们所说的那样。
Can you give me some examples of things that you have done already that speak to that, the idea of not leaving loose ends? of things that you have done already that speak to that, the idea of not leaving Luzenz? On my birthday, sometimes I like to get a gift to give to the kids or to my family on my birthday. And I said to my son, I said, do you remember a conversation that we had about 10 years ago, I was talking about when I would give you this watch. And he said, yeah, I remember that conversation when I would give you this watch. And he said, yeah, I remember that conversation. I said, you remember that I told you I'd give you this watch when I turned 54. Well, I'm 54 now. I took my watch off and I
你能给我举一些你已经做过的、说明这一点的例子吗，关于不留下悬念的想法？在我生日那天，有时我喜欢在生日那天给孩子们或家人一份礼物。我对我的儿子说，我说，你还记得大约10年前我们的一次谈话吗，我当时在谈论我什么时候会把这块表给你。他说，是的，我记得那次谈话，我什么时候会把这块表给你。他说，是的，我记得那次谈话。我说，你记得我告诉过你我会在我54岁时把这块表给你吗？好吧，我现在54岁了。我摘下我的表，我……
gave it to my son. He doesn't know the significance of 54 and still doesn't even after this weekend, after I gave it to him. even after this weekend, after I gave it to him. In Paul's mind, the gift to his son might not have made sense in the moment, but it would make sense once he died. It reflected a change in the way Paul was thinking. He had spent the better part of 30 years worrying about his own mortality. Now, he found himself turning his attention outward, asking what he could do for others before he died. I'm not convinced that it's true that it's going to happen or anything like that.
……把它给了我的儿子。他不知道54岁的意义，即使在这个周末之后，在我把它给他之后，他仍然不知道。在保罗看来，给儿子的礼物在当时可能没有意义，但一旦他去世，它就会有意义。它反映了保罗思考方式的改变。他花了30年的大部分时间担心自己的死亡。现在，他发现自己将注意力转向了外部，询问在去世前他能为别人做些什么。我不相信这是真的，它会发生或类似的事情。
But at the same time, I think the, maybe the action that I take isn't so much to keep myself safe, but rather just to live with a lot of intention this year and to really pay attention to how I'm interacting with other people. If I have any feeling that this is for a day, then what I'm going to do is live my best life, I guess. Yeah. I mean, in some ways you could argue this is what everyone should be doing, right? You might do is live my best life, I guess. Yeah. Mm-hmm. I mean, in some ways, you could argue this is what everyone should be doing, right? You might not know you're going to die at 8.54, but you know you're going to die at some
但与此同时，我认为，也许我采取的行动与其说是为了保持自己的安全，不如说是今年要非常有意识地生活，并真正注意我如何与他人互动。如果我有任何感觉这是最后一天，那么我要做的就是过我最好的生活，我想。是的。我的意思是，在某种程度上你可以说这就是每个人都应该做的，对吧？你可能不知道你会死在54岁，但你知道你会在某个……
point and, you know, given the vastness of time and space, you're going to die sometime in the near future. Near future being, you know, maybe several decades away, but in the vastness of time and space, that is still the near future. Right. And given that, it makes, eminently, it's eminently good sense to actually live your life,
……点死去，而且，你知道，考虑到时间和空间的广阔，你会在不久的将来某个时候死去。不久的将来是，你知道，也许几十年后，但在时间和空间的广阔中，那仍然是不久的将来。对。考虑到这一点，实际上过你认为你应该过的生活并对此深思熟虑，是极其有意义的。
the way you think you should be living your life and to be deliberate about it. I think so. I think this just makes it more clear, more plain that if I look at this and tell myself, hey, okay, I've got one year or I've got six months, then I'm going to focus all of that energy doing those things that I that I that I really want to do to make my life, my family's life, my neighbors and community
我想是的。我认为这只是让它变得更清晰、更明白，如果我看着这个并告诉自己，嘿，好吧，我还有一年或我还有六个月，那么我将把所有的精力都集中在做那些我真正想做的事情上，让我的生活、我家人的生活、我的邻居和社区……
of a better place. I think this has just brought that into focus maybe. That became clear at the end of the interview as we were chit chatting about what Paul was going to do the rest of the day. He told me he was going to celebrate his 54th birthday by donating blood. When I was 25 or 30 somewhere in there, I did make a goal to donate 100 units of blood. And I hit that goal in May of this year. Wow. I thought it was interesting that I had set that goal and then to donate 100 units of blood over my lifetime. And here I was in my 54th year and I had reached that goal. I thought, well, there it is. I reached my goal, I'm done.
……成为一个更好的地方。我想这只是让它变得清晰了。在采访结束时，当我们闲聊保罗余下的一天要做什么时，这一点变得很清楚。他告诉我他打算通过献血来庆祝他的54岁生日。当我25或30岁左右时，我确实设定了一个捐献100个单位血液的目标。我在今年5月实现了那个目标。哇。我觉得很有趣的是，我设定了那个目标，然后在我的一生中捐献100个单位的血液。而现在我处于54岁这一年，我已经达到了那个目标。我想，好吧，就是这样。我达到了我的目标，我完成了。
But I've started to think about that again and feel like maybe I'll set that goal again and see if I can reach another hundred units of blood. And my first appointment is this evening at 6.30. I'm going to give blood again. Doing all right My name is Nikki, I get to go in here. Paul Burnham? Yes. 12 gallons. I made a goal to do 100 units years ago and I hit it. Yeah, that's awesome.
但我开始再次思考这个问题，觉得也许我会再次设定那个目标，看看我是否能再达到100个单位的血液。我的第一次预约是今天晚上6点半。我要再次献血。做得好。我叫尼基，我可以进去吗？保罗·伯纳姆？是的。12加仑。我几年前设定了一个捐献100个单位的目标，我达到了。是的，那太棒了。
And then you like, I gotta keep going. I gotta come back. Yeah. A few months passed and I didn't hear from Paul. Then one day he sent me an email saying that he had brought up the episode of Lost Again with his family. And to a surprise, they had changed their minds. Now they said they would want to know if a family member was going to die. Shortly after I got that email, I asked Paul how he would feel telling Kim, with me present in the room. He thought it over and decided he would do it. Kim agreed
然后你就像，我得继续。我得回来。是的。几个月过去了，我没有收到保罗的消息。然后有一天他给我发了一封电子邮件，说他再次和家人提起了《迷失》的那一集。令他惊讶的是，他们改变了主意。现在他们说如果家庭成员要去世，他们想知道。收到那封邮件后不久，我问保罗，如果我在场，他会如何告诉金。他考虑了一下，决定他会这样做。金同意……
to meet. He didn't tell her what the dreams were about though. I went to Salt Lake City and invited Paul and Kim over to my hotel for a chat over breakfast. Paul, how are you? Good, thank you. Nice to meet you. This was Kim. Good morning. Please come in. Thank you.
……见面。但他没有告诉她梦的内容。我去了盐湖城，邀请保罗和金到我的酒店吃早餐聊天。保罗，你好吗？很好，谢谢。很高兴见到你。这是金。早上好。请进。谢谢。
I'm going to have you sit on this side and that's okay. Paul was friendly and genuine. Kim seemed a little hesitant. Why was her husband telling her about some dreams with a journalist and microphone's present? We sat down and I passed around some yogurt and muffins. I'm Paul Burnham and I live in Pleasant Grove, Utah. I'm Kim Burnham and happy to be here. I started by asking Kim how she and Paul first met. So I have a cousin. She told that origin story with the ease of someone who's recounted dozens of times,
我要让你坐在这一边，没关系。保罗很友好、真诚。金看起来有点犹豫。为什么她的丈夫要和一个记者在有麦克风的情况下告诉她一些梦？我们坐下来，我分发了一些酸奶和松饼。我是保罗·伯纳姆，我住在犹他州的普莱森特格罗夫。我是金·伯纳姆，很高兴来到这里。我首先问金她和保罗是怎么认识的。所以我有一个表妹。她以一个讲述过几十次的人的轻松感讲述了那个起源故事，
but still found it entertaining. My cousin kept telling me, oh, I've got this guy. I need to introduce you to and then he'd write into Paul and say, oh, I've got this girl. I need to introduce you to. And so that went back and forth for a while. Paul and I had already met. We met at a little apartment party. It started dating, and my cousin said,
但仍然觉得它很有趣。我的表妹一直告诉我，哦，我有这个家伙。我需要把你介绍给他，然后他会写信给保罗说，哦，我有这个女孩。我需要把你介绍给她。所以这来回持续了一段时间。保罗和我已经见过面了。我们在一个小公寓聚会上认识的。开始约会，我的表妹说，
hey, Paul, I've got to introduce you to my cousin. And Paul said, well, I'm kind of dating this girl, and it's getting kind of serious, and turns out it was me, so. It was kind of an interesting way to meet our first date. They got married in 1992. Paul became a civil engineer. Kim, an elementary school teacher. I asked Kim to tell me more about the man I'd been talking to for a year and a half. I think one of my favorite things about Paul is his generosity. He's a very kind and generous person and helps me to want to be better.
嘿，保罗，我得把你介绍给我表妹。保罗说，嗯，我正在和一个女孩约会，关系变得有点认真了，结果发现那个人就是我，所以。这是一种很有趣的初次约会方式。他们在1992年结婚。保罗成为了一名土木工程师。金是一名小学老师。我请金多跟我讲讲我聊了一年半的这个男人。我想我最喜欢保罗的一点是他的慷慨。他是一个非常善良和慷慨的人，这让我想要变得更好。
He's quiet and thinks and kind of watches and reads people and I'm a little more impulsive. So. I asked Paul to tell Kim about the two dreams. He told her about the first one, seeing the canyons, the bend and the river, the break and the cliffs. As I was traveling along the bottom of this canyon, I couldn't really tell if the bottom of the canyon was a river or if it was a road or exactly what it was. And he told her about his experience in Alaska when the dream came true.
他很安静，喜欢思考，喜欢观察和解读他人，而我则稍微冲动一些。所以，我请保罗给金讲讲那两个梦。他告诉她第一个梦，梦见峡谷、河流的弯道、悬崖的断层。当我在峡谷底部穿行时，我真的分不清峡谷底部是河流还是道路，或者到底是什么。他还告诉了她他在阿拉斯加时那个梦成真的经历。
I started to feel like I've seen this place before. These tall cliffs, the flat floor of the canyon, and there was a bend coming up that we couldn't see or hear. And so we throttled back the engine. I'm wondering, Kim, if I can ask you, what do you make of this dream? And do you have any thoughts about it? How are you hearing the story? Well, most of the time I don't remember my dreams and Paul seems to be able to remember
我开始觉得我以前见过这个地方。这些高耸的悬崖，平坦的峡谷底部，前面有一个我们看不见也听不见的弯道。于是我们减小了引擎油门。金，我想问问你，你觉得这个梦意味着什么？你对此有什么想法吗？你是怎么看待这个故事的？嗯，大多数时候我不记得我的梦，而保罗似乎能记住
his dreams in the morning. I don't know that there really are so many coincidences. It feels like a lot of things happen that we attribute to being a coincidence and maybe it's not. It just makes me really interested to know what the next dream is. So... I might be a little emotional here. This is the dream that I've just kind of held on to for all these years.
他早上的梦。我不知道这世上是否真的有那么多巧合。感觉很多事情发生时我们都归结为巧合，也许并非如此。这让我非常想知道下一个梦是什么。所以……我可能有点情绪化了。这就是我多年来一直记在心里的那个梦。
So I went back to sleep and the second dream was that I had one of these little paper games. When I opened this paper up, I would see how long I would live. I played the game, and I opened it, and then I was 54. Paul told her about the second dream. He told her how long he had held on to the secret. I glanced over at Kim and saw tears streaming down her cheeks. If anyone knows Paul, you know that he really spends his life trying to make everyone else's life better. And we've built our life together. It worries me that he's had one dream come true, and I don't want this one too.
所以我又睡着了，第二个梦是我玩着一种纸折的小游戏。当我打开这张纸时，我会看到我能活多久。我玩了这个游戏，打开它，上面写着54岁。保罗告诉了她第二个梦。他告诉她他把这个秘密藏了多久。我瞥了一眼金，看到泪水顺着她的脸颊流下。如果有人了解保罗，就会知道他一生都在努力让别人的生活变得更好。我们一起建立了我们的生活。他有一个梦成真了，这让我很担心，我不希望这个梦也成真。
Nor do I. You know, it just worries me. I don't like it. I don't want to do life without him. We do life well together. And we have a family together and we both contribute very different things to our family. But it's our family, it's ours, and it's not something that I
我也不希望。你知道，这让我很担心。我不喜欢这样。我不想没有他独自生活。我们一起生活得很好。我们有一个共同的家庭，我们都为家庭贡献了非常不同的东西。但这是我们的家，它是属于我们的，这不是我
want to do alone. The three of us sat there in silence for a moment. I think it could come true. I mean, that's probably why I'm crying. I don't know. I don't know what to say. I think I'm never going to do kudikechers again with my fifth graders. We do those to practice per math facts and we won't be doing that anymore. Is that what those papers are called? Kudikechers. I never knew what they were called. Well, they're called kudikechers in fifth grade language. So, yeah, it does language. So yeah, it does seem like that's plausible just because the other one happened. We've loved each other a long time and he's a part of me and I'm a part of him and so yeah, that worries me. Do you think that dream is going to come true? You know, I've had dreams that are
想要独自面对的事情。我们三个人沉默了一会儿。我想它可能会成真。我是说，这可能就是我哭的原因。我不知道。我不知道该说什么。我想我再也不会和我的五年级学生玩“东南西北”折纸游戏了。我们玩那个是为了练习数学题，以后不会再玩了。那种纸折游戏叫“东南西北”吗？我以前从不知道它叫什么。嗯，在五年级的语言里它叫“东南西北”。所以，是的，这看起来确实很有可能，因为第一个梦已经发生了。我们相爱很久了，他是我的生命的一部分，我也是他生命的一部分，所以是的，这让我很担心。你认为那个梦会成真吗？你知道，我做过一些
common, you know, breathing underwater. I think everyone's had that dream, and then other times I've had dreams where my legs are long and I can run, I can outrun anyone and anything. We all have so many different dreams and they never come true. And so when I think about this dream of 54, for a long time, I thought it's going to come true because the other one came true. But I'm a few months into 54 and I feel like maybe I'm going to make it through. Let's plan on that. Okay. Let's plan on that. You've been carrying this since you were 15. Have you done things differently because you've had this out in front of you?
常见的梦，比如在水下呼吸。我想每个人都做过那个梦，还有时候我梦见我的腿很长，我可以奔跑，我可以跑得比任何人、任何东西都快。我们都有很多不同的梦，但它们从未成真。所以当我想到这个54岁的梦时，很长一段时间里，我以为它会成真，因为第一个梦成真了。但我已经过了54岁几个月了，我觉得也许我能挺过去。我们就按这个计划吧。好的。我们就按这个计划。你从15岁起就一直带着这个心结。因为这件事一直摆在你面前，你做事情的方式有什么不同吗？
I think just recently, just this year, I feel like I've tried to be a little bit more aware. So, yeah, I have tried to be more careful. Has it affected any, like, our relationship? How is knowing that that date as I had, has that had any effect on, like, you and I? I don't think so. I don't think things have changed. Do you love me more, wondering if you're going to die. I love you. And I don't think any of this changes how much I love you. I think maybe the biggest way this is changed what I'm doing or how I approach things is in how I interact with other people,
我想就在最近，就在今年，我觉得我试着更加清醒一点。所以，是的，我试着更加小心。这影响了我们的关系吗？知道那个日期对我有什么影响吗？这对我俩有什么影响吗？我不这么认为。我不觉得事情有什么改变。你更爱我了吗，因为担心我会死？我爱你。我不认为这一切改变了我爱你的程度。我想这对我改变最大的是我做事的方式，或者我处理事情的方法，以及我与他人互动的方式，
especially with my family but also with people I work with and complete strangers. And so if indeed this is the last year of my life, I wanted to focus on that thing that's most important and that is the relationships with people. I would say you live with integrity that you do live what's important to you. I'm going to really try to pull it together. I'm tired of crying now. But this is a lot for me to take in today. for me to take in today. As they got ready to leave, Paul and Kim discussed his 55th birthday.
尤其是与我的家人，还有与我的同事以及完全陌生的人。所以，如果这真的是我生命的最后一年，我想专注于最重要的事情，那就是人际关系。我会说你活得很有原则，你确实在践行对你重要的事情。我真的要努力控制一下。我哭累了。但今天对我来说信息量太大了。在他们准备离开时，保罗和金讨论了他的55岁生日。
I will say that I'm really looking forward to this birthday. Yeah, we need to plan something big. We need to plan something big. Yeah. What's going on trip? Okay, but we have to be careful. And maybe leave the day after. In one of our final conversations, I asked Paul how he would live his life after he turned 55 in September. I see turning 55 as being really positive for two reasons. I've made it to 55, right? I made it through,
我会说我真的很期待这个生日。是的，我们需要计划一些盛大的活动。我们需要计划一些盛大的活动。是的。去旅行怎么样？好的，但我们必须小心。也许第二天再出发。在最后几次谈话中，我问保罗在九月过了55岁生日后他会如何生活。我认为55岁是一个非常积极的里程碑，原因有二。我活到了55岁，对吧？我挺过来了，
but also it's kind of the proverbial icing on the cake. For a long time I felt like maybe I'll only make it to 54. And now I've made it beyond that when I turn 55. And I think I will carry a lot of that positivity with me, a lot of that that I've learned over this last year to value people and relationships and events and experiences. I think I will carry that with me. The more I talk with Paul, the more I realized his story is a universal story. The way he is thinking about his life is the way we should all think about our lives.
而且这就像是锦上添花。很长一段时间里，我以为我可能只能活到54岁。现在我过了55岁。我想我会带着很多这种积极的态度，带着我在过去一年里学到的东西——去珍视人、关系、事件和经历。我想我会带着这些继续前行。我与保罗交谈得越多，就越意识到他的故事是一个普遍的故事。他思考生活的方式，正是我们所有人都应该思考生活的方式。
Instead of worrying about our own mortality, more of us ought to say, I'm grateful to have gotten this far. And if I get any more time, well, that's just icing. Hittin' Brain is produced by Hittin' Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Kristen Wong, Annie Murphy Paul, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Jamie Stillings.
与其担心我们自己的死亡，我们更多人应该说，我很感激能走到这一步。如果我还能得到更多的时间，嗯，那只是锦上添花。《Hidden Brain》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy、Kristen Wong、Annie Murphy Paul、Laura Quarelle、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes和Andrew Chadwick。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是Jamie Stillings。
Jamie is a photographer in New Mexico. We recently met on the sidelines of the Ted Conference in Vancouver. He heard my talk and reached out to us to make a portrait of me. We carved out some time to meet, and he made a few images that made me look a lot better than I do. If you want to see one of those photos, go to hiddenbrain.org slash mission. Thank you Jamie, for making me think I don't have a face for radio. If you liked today's episode, please share it with a few people.
Jamie是新墨西哥州的一位摄影师。我们最近在温哥华的TED大会场边相遇。他听了我的演讲，并主动联系我们为我拍摄肖像。我们抽出时间见了面，他拍了几张照片，让我看起来比本人好多了。如果你想看其中一张照片，请访问hiddenbrain.org/mission。谢谢你，Jamie，让我觉得我不是那种“长得不适合做广播”的人。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请分享给几个人。
If your friends are new to podcasting, please show them how they can sign up for our show and get all of our episodes. And if you'd like to hear more stories like this, you can help us make them. Go to support.hiddenbrain.org. That's support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vidantan. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你的朋友是播客新手，请教他们如何订阅我们的节目并获取我们所有的剧集。如果你想听到更多这样的故事，你可以帮助我们制作它们。请访问support.hiddenbrain.org。网址是support.hiddenbrain.org。我是Shankar Vedantam。再见。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。